hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom
live stream we have a very exciting
guest today
ceo of at t john sandki is here so start
putting your questions on facebook and
youtube wherever you're watching it and
i will try to get as many of them as
possible uh to john a lot to talk about
but before we jump into that i will give
my standard announcements reminder to
everyone that we are not for profit so
if you can make your way to khan
academy.org donate and if you're in a
position to do so please think about
making a donation it really really makes
a difference i also want to give a
special shout out to several
organizations that have stepped up
really over the years but especially
during kovid when they realized that the
world was more dependent on khan academy
than ever uh but also our costs have
gone up our traffic had increased we're
trying to put more content support
programs training for teachers and
parents so special thanks to bank of
america google.org att
fastly and novartis for that support
it's really really been a big deal but
if you're a position to do so all of you
all listening please think about
continuing to support because we we
continue to need help in filling our gap
also want to uh remind folks that a
version of this
live stream is available wherever you
get your podcast at homeroom with sal
the podcast
with that i'm really excited to
introduce our guest john stanky the ceo
of a of a small startup called att
john john
thanks thanks for joining us
sal thanks for having me and you know
what big fans we are the work you do at
khan academy
at att so it's a real treat for me to be
part of the curriculum today
well no and i do have to thank y'all i
mean it is it is a really big deal the
work that you all do i mean on on a
bunch of levels and we're going to talk
a lot about things like internet access
and digital divide because obviously we
can't do our work and reach the folks
who need it most without that existing
but y'all over the years not just during
covid have been big supporters of khan
academy and that really means a lot so
everyone listening if you're able to
benefit from khan academy it's 18t and
organizations like it that really allow
us uh to to do this work uh but you know
john maybe a good a good place to start
you know you are relatively new in the
job at at t it's 18t is a storied
institution for you know maybe the
younger people who didn't know it's not
a startup it's a very very well
established
um you know
what was kind of your thought process as
you've as you've taken the role and as
you're taking this you know i would call
att as kind of one of the institutions
of america or the world uh
how are you viewing that
well you know it's interesting you use
the analogy startup and i know you kind
of did it in jess but
the reality is well it's a storied
institution that's been around for
a very very long time
you know just about every line of
business that we operate in right now is
in a major state of transition
and transformation and so
even an established company like att i
think there's so many
different industries and so many large
established businesses because of
not only cova but what's just going on
in the economy in general that are all
undergoing some pretty rapid and
significant change and we're no
exception to that and as a result of
that
well it's a big company and we have
several large lines of businesses
each one of those inside the company is
going through its own transition and
transformation and so it's a very
exciting time to come into this role
uh it's a bit of a humbling time as you
indicated which
so many of things that we do right now
in this covent environment are dependent
on the networks and the infrastructure
that we provide and i'm reminded that of
that every day sometimes positive
comments coming back
from our customers talking about how
they're surviving and living their lives
and doing the things that they must do
because of the services we provide but
also
i sometimes hear about that moment when
the service doesn't work on a given day
and just how significant an interruption
is to somebody's well-being in their
their daily existence if that happens
and puts a lot of pressure on the
organization but i've been
really pleased with how overall the
business has performed how our employees
have stepped up to ensuring services
work during this critical time and i i
couldn't be more happy about the new
relevance that i think people have found
in our services in this moment
and where do you see your focal point i
mean given what's going on in kovid uh
you know you've written a lot about the
need for
you know solving the digital divide
issue obviously y'all have been key
actors in this you all really been doing
great things when it comes to getting
communities through this covid period
especially communities that did not have
internet access making it far more
accessible what are the programs that
you've done in the short term and how
are you thinking about this long term
how do we
solve the digital divide issue
you know it's it's interesting because
um in some regards there's that old
analogy of the old house that needs a
lot of structural work that sometimes
you put a little bit of plaster or
spackling over
cracks to hide them and i and i would
say maybe pre-covered
that might have been the state of
internet access in the united states in
some regards
some very robust and capable wireless
networks have been built and
and many individuals were getting their
access to the internet and frankly
living their life in a pretty okay
fashion
with wireless as their answer to the
problem and they made a basic utility
and value call and said for what i need
to do in my life and the things i need
access for
having a smartphone is is adequate and
that's given that i've got to worry
about putting food on the table or going
to see the doctor next month
it was a luxury to think about having
both a wireless connection
and a fixed connection so many people
chose not to do that
and as as a result of covid i think what
we've seen is well that might have
worked before
when somebody's at home and is having to
live on the internet 24 hours a day
sit in a classroom watch a teacher
keep their attention on maybe a
multi-screen format with a speaker and
other content showing up you know
there's limitations to that three and a
half or four inch screen
that everybody depends on and carries
around their pocket every day
and there's limitations in the
robustness of a wireless network
compared to fixed networks so we've
really seen that this this dynamic of
the 17 million students that don't have
access
to fix broadband becomes a a problem in
this environment
and when you think about all the work
that you know companies
organizations sorry like yourselves have
done
in building great curriculum that can be
consumed at home you really need that
robust infrastructure you need the
ability to sit with a larger screen and
have an experience and so you know we're
looking at this two-fold one is
there's a public policy issue that needs
to be dealt with and we're leaning into
that at a t in fact i'm starting to
orient the company and all of the work
we're doing around our charitable giving
what we're trying to do in policy
advocacy
how we're engaging our employees and
their working communities to start
working on the issues that affect those
17 million students
and probably 24 million households that
really don't have that robust fixed
access to the internet and that's policy
shifts that need to occur
in some cases you know we've got a lot
of subsidy
that are part of our tax structure
that maybe is not being directed as
effectively as it could
in some cases maybe we need new
ways to subsidize service for those who
can't afford to pay for it
and trying to get that policy structure
proper
i would also tell you there's certain
things that we need to do to facilitate
the ecosystem we know that just
providing discounted access isn't enough
we
we provide 10 a month access for
low-income households is one of the
services we provided att
we found that wasn't enough because many
homes don't have access to the tablet or
the laptop computer that they need to
really use that access in an effective
way so putting vehicles in place where
we started to donate money into
entities that help solve
that complete ecosystem of what a
household needs for distance learning
and access to the internet
and then you know we want this to be
done in a sustainable fashion and we
think that you need good
robust infrastructure and while we're
continuing to invest
aggressively in the core parts of our
business the core parts of our network
and we'll be
making some announcements here shortly
about stepping up fiber investment
um look there's parts of the united
states that just aren't that dense
and as a result of that we need to think
about policy that supports
access into rural areas with adequate
broadband to be able to do most of
things that many households take for
granted in suburban or urban areas and
and starting to try to drive policy
adoption in that regard
i'm curious actually i want to double
click on each of those but on that last
point just kind of the the telecom nerd
inside of me wants to make sure i
understand thing you know for everyone
listening you can you know dig up uh
kind of the ground and put fiber in it
which is a very expensive proposition
and then that can get real you know
really good quality access to a lot of
folks but to your point if you're in
some rural place it could be very cost
prohibitive to make sure that every
what's called farm has fiber running
through it
but you think that there's ways to do
wireless access that could get us close
or get have the sufficiently high
bandwidth and reliability to uh to meet
those folks needs
if you think about it from a public
policy perspective
you go back decades in the united states
had a policy that it felt like
everybody should get access to the
telephone network and that universal
access construct
was established many years ago with
overt policy
around subsidy around
how do we make sure that even the farm
house in a rural area was able to get on
the network but if everybody paid their
true cost of that service there's no way
that farm house ever would have been
connected the cost would have been
so prohibitive nobody would have ever
built those you know small twisted cop
repair wires to that home so they we
averaged pricing
across the united states with the
deliberate policy approach to ensure
that we eventually got you know 98 of us
households onto the telephone network
we're at that same moment for the
internet
and when we think about solving that
problem
if if that's the case there's probably
going to be some degree of subsidy that
comes in which may mean public money
taxpayer money and i don't think the
answer to that is that we want to go and
over build and have fiber out to a
farmhouse where it might cost
10 times the amount it does in a
suburban or rural area but can we get
the benefits of getting on the internet
with adequate bandwidth and maybe a
lower cost alternative maybe something
that's only
two times as expensive as what it might
take in our urban or suburban area but
still get most of the benefits of being
on the internet and and so one of the
policy positions we believe is important
is a is a technology agnostic point of
view
get the most effective way to get the
right amount of bandwidth out to every
home and in some cases to your point it
might be using the latest
uh technology around wireless services
like 5g
but in some cases the answer may be a
different technology possibly
low earth orbiting satellites and what's
coming up with leo capabilities and that
might be the more effective way to get
to some highly rural households
and in some areas there may be a
opportunity is infrastructure is being
deployed for power electricity to also
piggyback fiber in there the point is
you want to do the right thing at the
right time in the right house
but not overspend taxpayer money to gold
plate things that ultimately don't need
to be gold-plated and we're trying to
provide some frameworks now as we work
with policymakers on understanding where
those cutoffs are and how we think about
that deployment of infrastructure moving
forward
and a quick technical question what's
the leo capability
so um if you think about satellite
technology that's been in place
for many you know decades typically you
put a satellite way up high in orbit and
it sits over a particular part of the
united states and it's geostationary and
it follows you know that particular part
of the geography constantly
with leo you know these these satellites
are much smaller a lower i see
less expensive
um you put them up you know much lower
in the atmosphere
they don't last as long but because
they're so much less expensive you can
cover a much
broader part of the united states with
allowing them to work in a
non-geostationary fashion
encircle the globe and this new
technology opens up some opportunities
in some rural areas that weren't there
before
and what you just described is you know
do it essentially saying do it's
rational there's multiple ways of
getting internet access it could be a
you know fiber it could be low earth
orbiting satellites it could be you know
5g networks is there a resistance of
this or is it just kind of we have old
laws on the books that tend to be very
focused on
landlines essentially
oh you know i think any time you get
into a policy debate sometimes
um there are those that are very
knowledgeable about a policy and
very well informed there are others who
maybe tend to gravitate more to the
sound bite
and the sound bite is you know everybody
needs fiber and
certainly an ideal world would it be
great if every household in the united
states is connected to fiber sure that'd
be wonderful but again i don't think
that's the optimal use of public funds
um one of the things that people like to
go and reference is they say well you
know look korea how can so many homes in
korea be connected to fiber well you
know korea actually isn't you know quite
the size of the united states
they don't have you know square states
sitting in the middle of it with a lot
of open territory and pasture land like
the united states has
so when you have a vertical society the
ability to get fiber into most
households is quite a bit different than
when you have a a more you know
horizontal society like the united
states and you have to use different
solutions to that so i think those that
are informed and know the engineering
and the economics behind it understand
that this needs to be a
technology agnostic solution that we
need to use all the tools that we have
in the toolbox to address this
effectively and frankly fast because you
know trenching fiber everywhere takes
time whereas some wireless solutions may
get a lot of bandwidth out fairly
quickly
because of the nature of how that
infrastructure is deployed but i think
it's just informing folks with the fact
based so that everybody can have a fully
informed conversation about it
and one thing you've alluded to this
kind of notion of public-private
partnership and i think telecom you know
growing up that telecom was one thing
that i always got confused about it's
like okay who's digging who's digging
those trenches is that the government or
is that the 18 t's of the world who is
providing the subsidy explain how that
works you know my understanding it is
it's private companies like att that are
putting the cost
behind the investment by putting the
infrastructure but the government
provides uh subsidies discounts
incentives
how does that interplay work
it's it's a complicated question and
there's a lot of layers to it i would
tell you if you think about it at its
most basic level
the the policy up to this point in time
in the united states which has largely
been a market-based policy for broadband
infrastructure deployment has actually
worked quite well
if you think about what's happened in
coming into the pandemic with these
dramatic increases in traffic you know
people are not sitting around talking
about the fact that you and i can't
conduct this session
and at the same time i'm still not able
to watch you know my netflix down the
hall that most of that's working pretty
well if you live in a urban a suburb
suburban setting in the united states
and so policy has been really good where
markets are competitive driving that
level of investment
but there are places in the united
states where because of the density
characteristics of how people live
that market approach isn't quite enough
to incent that investment in broadband
and
there have been
subsidy models coming in to try to
incent
uh companies to go
get some help from different government
funds to offset the additional costs and
then go in and build in these
territories and they've been successful
to a degree
but they haven't been you know quite as
successful as they need to be if there's
still you know a large number of rural
households maybe you know 24 million
non-broadband connected i bet 70 80
percent of those
are in rural areas of the united states
we clearly need to think about a little
bit different subsidy structure and i
think this is where
as the government starts to deal with
things like infrastructure deployment
and maybe the early stages of a biden
administration
getting those incentives right and
explicit and setting companies like a t
or
cable companies or other telcos to go in
and build that infrastructure that
opportunity is in front of us
we've had great success with some of
those programs in the past
um another subsidy program that you may
be familiar with is e-rate e-rate was
targeted at getting all of our schools
in the united states connected it was a
deliberate subsidy program that caused
for low-imp low
cost infrastructure to be deployed into
every school and library in the us and
it's been tremendously successful
and everybody thought well you know
check that box it's great we've solved
the problem in education until all of
our students started leaving the
schoolhouse and going home to learn now
the school was connected but we couldn't
get to the end points the students at
home and this is the next stage that we
kind of have to deal with
and
given you know there's likely to be
multiple rounds of stimulus going
forward over the next several months if
you know what are the two or three
policy levers that you hope happens
over the next
few months i think we have to think
about the subsidy and look at how it's
used today
and have it kind of come together in a
more focused approach so
there's you know 10 mil 10 billion over
here in rural
subsidy there's two and a half billion
over here and what we do for the next
version of e-rate in schools there's
what we do in universal service
structure that comes in i think in some
regards stepping back and saying if our
goal is to get everybody on the internet
let's make sure we take some of those
programs
aggregate them and focus on that be one
two
look if you're going to have to go in
and do overt subsidy then we should
think about what the right mechanism is
to do that and i i think in an
appropriations fashion
congress ought to be realistic about it
whereas today
some of these subsidies are set up on
dying infrastructure for example the
universal service fund that supports
voice service for access today
is built on top of fixed telephone line
service well if fixed telephone line
services are doing this and there's
fewer and fewer subscribers
what happens to that subsidy pool it
disappears eventually as everybody goes
to wireless services for voice so we
need to step back
make sure that those subsidy structures
are put on mechanisms that are
sustainable and that are fair to the
industry in total
i don't think we should be limiting our
thought process around
how we attach
that tax structure to a particular
product or service the internet has
changed so much how people make their
money and what services they use and we
think about how the edge providers the
facebooks the googles the amazons of the
world who have benefited so much from
infrastructure deployment and the
capabilities of the internet
maybe we need to think about the base
under which we subsidize to come back on
a broader set of services
as we go forward that are more relevant
for the going forward position and not
based on you know the decades of old
when we think about voice telephone
service so i think that's a dynamic that
we probably need to come to grips with
and then look you know understanding
exactly where the problems are believe
it or not a country is
as effective and capable as the united
states
we actually don't have really good data
and information around where our
problems are
on how infrastructure is deployed you
know att has a point of view on the
markets that we serve in the homes that
we handle but nobody really has a good
picture of what the united states looks
like in total because there are places
in the u.s we don't service we don't
have infrastructure and so knowing where
we need to put that subsidy
have that policy change to drive the
right kind of investment and where the
market will take care of it is based on
really good data and that data and
funding the ability to ensure that we've
got a good mapping of what the
circumstances are in the united states
is another key element i think of what
happens to inform really good policy
moving forward
and what do you think the odds are it'll
happen do you think people are people
you're talking to are aligned
you know you would think i think there's
good probability it can happen although
you know i i'm the last person to
prognosticate on
something coming out of washington it's
often times hard to
get the calculus of things but if if you
think about it today it's it's truly a
bipartisan issue as you know many people
you've had
as guests here will talk about
everybody's in favor of education
i think everybody understands that it's
a it's a key issue to equality it's a
key issue to opportunity
shouldn't be a democratic or a
republican issue
it should just be it's good for our
society as a whole so you you start from
that point of view
second thing i would say is that the
dynamics kind of line up really well
if you think about red states today
many of those tend to be rural in nature
they have an internet access problem and
if you think about urban dynamics which
tends to be you know more a democrat
stronghold
they have an internet access problem and
so if the two sides can get together and
figure out what we do in urban and what
we do to deal with rural then you would
think you have a natural coalition of
folks that want to solve that problem
infrastructure has traditionally been a
bipartisan issue so you know if there is
something that it would seem like there
might be an ability to not only get some
good policy done
but figure out how we
drive spending in the right place to
come out of the covid dynamic to
equalize education to stimulate the
economy to help telehealth it feels like
there's enough good news there for
everybody
that they should want to be part of
solving this problem
yeah i couldn't agree more i i've and
and i do feel like they're the energy
behind this issue i've never seen more
energy so so fingers fingers crossed in
the remaining time you know there's a
bunch of questions that have come in and
you know some of them are just on on
your journey uh
where you know susannah garcia dominguez
from youtube is asking hi mr stanky
please tell us about your journey to
become ceo who are your heroes and and
how do you reboot or re-energize to keep
your life in balance during these these
trying times yeah how did you get to
where you are and how do you how do you
handle it
you know it's a it's a really good
question and i i'm always reticent to
answer this question because
you know i i and i tell my children this
i grew up
at a different time in a different
united states
in a different way of learning
than what is the norm today and
certainly
probably a different social contract and
different set of companies that were
relevant in the united states
uh than what you know a a young aspiring
professional
might encounter today and so you know
when somebody asked me for advice
what i say is don't do it the way i did
it because that probably won't work
anymore
um you know what i did is i i ended up
spending a lot of time and becoming
quite deep
in an industry and building expertise
in a particular industry i think
i had some lessons along the way when i
was young
it taught me an early age the value of
hard work
and you know keeping your head down and
trying to do things well and if that
happened then eventually you would be
recognized for it and i was fortunate
enough
in some cases maybe even lucky enough
to come along in my career with a couple
of uh individuals
that took an interest in my career that
helped me out that gave me opportunities
that allowed me to stretch and maybe do
some things that were beyond
what my capabilities on paper might have
said
lived up to those expectations and got
succeeding in increasing levels of
responsibility as a result of that
those lessons probably aren't any
different for today's environment but
what is different is you know i went
through the
the traditional degree structure get an
undergraduate degree
have some pedigree in it get an
opportunity to do a job maybe go get an
advanced degree
have some pedigree in it get an
opportunity to do something more
significant
i think that's so passe and it's not
that i don't value education it's quite
the opposite what i value
is a lifelong discipline to learning
and the reality is
i think the successful generations
moving forward
are going to be individuals who are very
disciplined and thinking about
in every day as they wake up in every
month and every quarter and every year
what are their objectives for their own
personal learning how are they going to
build a curriculum
on a variety of tools that are available
to them
to ensure
that they're dedicating their time and
energy to do that
and they have to realize it as this this
economy
is our environment has become more
global the internet has done that
you're competing with people all over
the globe who every day get up and have
access to some of the most remarkable
sets of information they've ever had and
if they're more motivated to get it
digest it and learn it than you are
they're probably going to be more
competitive professionally than you are
and so you've got to think about that as
you're your own chief learning officer
you've got to think about all the tools
capabilities are available to you
like the khan academy and others
how you're going to engage every day
to learn more and if you do that
i think you'll get
more opportunity you'll get increasing
levels of responsibility and you'll keep
your skills current
as things are moving and changing and
that i think has been
an incr is going to be an incredibly
important part of people's success
moving forward
balance
uh boy um you know i always talk about
it internally is
you have four dynamics in your life it's
like a box
and you want that box to be a perfect
square and the reality is
very few of us are ever really good at
making that box a perfect square it's
your
it's your personal relationships and
those people that are
important to you family
close friends that's one side of it
it's your personal
professional commitment what you do at
work and what satisfaction you get out
of that is one element of that box
the third element of it is
why do you get up in the morning and
what is your reason for being it might
be a set of religious beliefs but you
better be getting up every day
and thinking about the fact that there's
some greater entity you're serving
either your co-workers your fellow man
or somebody you know that's more
important than you
that drives you and the the final in the
fourth area of that box
is really your physical well-being
how healthy are you how well you take
care of this this vehicle that you have
to get through life in
you know everybody would rather probably
drive a porsche than ride a scooter
because the porsche performs better and
your body needs to be a porsche not a
scooter
and so your job is to think about your
life every day across those four
dimensions and when one side of that
square is out of balance
work to get it into balance or try to
keep it in balance
and i have to use a lot of discipline
it's self-evaluation
across those four dynamics
it's about setting limits
limits to how my professional life
creeps into my personal life how much
time i reserve in a given day to ensure
that my body still functions what am i
doing for my own mental renewal
you have to be very disciplined around
thinking about those things and not
being shy
about building the coping mechanisms and
specifics to ensure that you're spending
time in all four of those areas
well john i i could talk to you for a
few more hours about actually each of
these topics uh but uh
you you need to help keep the nation's
telecom infrastructure going so that we
can help the the nation keep learning uh
thank you so much for this incredible
conversation and thank you again for all
of your support over the years
well so thank you for everything you do
at the khan academy i'm more than happy
to be affiliated and proud i could spend
some time with you this afternoon thanks
thank you so much john
well everyone thank you for joining
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation
as much as i did um
i find john to be an inspirational
figure and i have light in my eyes now
the sun has moved um
i i really you know what i i hopefully
we can get them on in the future again
to talk about some of the the life work
bounce stuff which is i think you know
something that we're all trying to
struggle with these days uh but anyway
thanks for joining a lot of important
issues there uh our next uh live stream
will be on thursday where we have a
surprise guest we're going to actually
announce and meet the winner of the
breakthrough junior challenge which is
this incredible of challenge where
students from around the world submit
these videos explaining new concepts in
math and science and the winner gets
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of
prizes and scholarships so it'll be a
pretty fun conversation i predict
i will see you then
you